non so se sapete qual è stato il mio
primo video sul canale proprio il primo
in assoluto di famiglia in tv però e si
tratta di questo bella e tutti ragazzi
venuti a questo madonna che casino che
bel microfono favi jane che bel litorale
di parigi tv se siete su deleghe bene
fammi vedere i commenti poi james è più
quello di una volta vogliamo questo
aspetta nessuno che ha scritto quella
cagata
lo scrivo scrivo io adesso fai schifo
torna quello di prima sei cambiato lo
fai per i mon è andato a mettere mi
piace perché tutti devono vederlo come
stato un periodo gremito di giochi old
style ma come parlo bene ho deciso di
portare il primo gioco che ho fatto sul
canale slider out
se per anti fatto con un microfono che
non ti storpi alle orecchie anzi
facciamo l'intro come avevo fatto una
volta per tutti ragazzi voglio a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti che secondo sono fa
vj e faccio video se venite ad aleggiare
gaming ho aperto questo canale così
scrivete sono più bello chi sei tu no
gamer farisei sono trova bene cosa
faresti se ti svegliassi in un posto che
non è mai visto prima
mi rimetterei a dormire della serie ma
che cazzo ci faccio qui basta che ci sta
la nutella
questo lo diciamo un tempo non so se
lodetti quel video però era un po agli
inizi quindi non sapevo giocare bene
adesso so giocare bene tanto sto andando
molto spavaldo come se conoscessi il
gioco ma non mi ricordo assolutamente
una mazza prefiggo fair use somebody
show venir al grotto final four
qualcuno deve essere vi intorni dovrei
trovarlo e chiedere aiuto
certo ogni tanto mi capita di giocare
delle cagate che c'è questo in confronto
e oro quindi complimenti a shawn inspect
carpi four hands and displays an
inspector cava che puoi metterlo via sto
coso che non me ne frega niente
poi andiamo a leggere processiamo la
bibbia cosa non me ne ho capito ho
capito cosa devo fare per a ok in avanti
o permesso quando qualcuno scopre che
non è uscito il video di favi j
non l'avevo fatta questa battuta che è
strano gli avanti ragazzi non sono mi
cordon niente di giuro sono passati
quasi sei anni da quel giorno in cui ho
giocato a questo gioco sporco anche come
passa il tempo
come cambiano i miei capelli non fanno
sempre schifo welcome to green non si
vede niente ma perché illuminato
intanto sta torcia welcome to green park
vi prego andate lì poi a vedere il mio
primo video come come l'avevo fatto
rispetto a questi numeri non lo non lo
guardo non l'ho mai visto in realtà
quindi non so quanto sono cambiati
fatemelo sapere sarei curiosissimo di
vederlo usati affatichi che i corso
minuto schifoso l'aido per chi non
conoscesse lander man il gioco sta nel
trovare le pagine ok bisogna trovare le
otto pagine dello slam dermer radunarle
tutte quante per niente poi hai vinto il
problema è che non ce l'ho mai fatta
quindi non vi aspettate io ci riescano a
questo video però lo slider man dovrebbe
iniziare a comparire a un certo punto
nel mentre che speriamo ammazza quanto è
bello la vegetazione a perseo kay una
casa l'ho trovata non chiedetemi non mi
ricordavo neanche prendi ste batterie
bene vediamo cosa c'è l'inter permesso
mentre però è veloce veloce veloce
chiudi chiuchiù di fiori che sentono
minchia lega ma non me lo ricordavo che
facesse così paura porca vacca
ma i giochi di una volta erano veramente
spalle non come con l'acca agata di
granny questo è un gioco cribbio mi
chiamava fatto benissimo anche aprire le
porte la sola mi spaventano ha
seriamente
certo potremmo mente non sono meno tetro
porca vacca se metta se mette ansia o il
primo video che ho fatto sul canale
mette un asse incredibile vabbè qua c'è
scritto don't look back non guardare
dietro a nessuno va bene piano di sopra
permesso sono veramente contento di
guardare questa casa mi piace un sacco
questo gioco è tranquillo let me go
lasciami andare no un gas che ti lascia
voce qualcosa qua ma c'è una pagina
tranne 12 devo trovarmi in totale
siete scemi non ha donato la vera mente
12 e palle sono troppe 12 regala a c'è
un'altra
ecco la foto 3
mancano 10 ok via di qua veloci come il
fulmine guarderei volentieri dove siamo
il problema è che non vedo niente se
punto la torcia dice che qua c'è un
capannone tipo giusto
un lampione che capannone ma che è tutto
che sbrilluccica tutto che sfarfalla in
sto gioco ma scusami dove stiamo ora
infatti c'era il capannone ciao ragione
cos'è e non leggo porca vacca sono orbo
si può entrare qui permesso a ecco qua a
bunker in place like this pain cioè non
sono così skillato con l'inglese so che
vuol dire dolore qualcosa melo ma dopo
la cep qua dentro
ma cos'è e call of duty world at war
zombies
se qualcuno se lo ricorda per me se
sfarfalla qualcos'altro vi ammazzo vado
a svitare tutte le lampadine il mondo e
le schiaccio giuro che belli questi
posti tranquilli ho bisogno di pagine
datemi pagine non so dove siano non ho
idea però sono talmente tante che qua
c'è il disegno di un cesso
speriamo che non mi spunti là dietro
l'omino bello perché in questo caso non
saprei come scappare però ok se non c'è
niente me mi ammazzo cioè ma dai ma
veramente porca vanno fatto un
chilometro a piedi
ah ecco ma cosa non affatto paranormale
c'è e non c'è vabbè foto 4 ma il male
posso vedere le foto e paranormale anche
nel mio menù anche le altre lo sono
anche la chiave non mi spuntare non mi
spuntare non riscontrare nomi spuntano
nomi spuntano disponibile sputare
disputare le slovene and the king of
this land airmen gaines più che dei fari
j
ju boss e ragazzi vedo una forma ambigua
là in fondo
ancora nessuna traccia dell'uomo bello
però l'ombra lì non mi convince
tantissima beh io ci vado
le cose che non mi convincono sono
quelle da qui vado sempre speriamo che
non ci siano luci che sfarfallano per
qua io comunque ho una chiave che prima
o poi userò si spera in dio ma che è
ma porca vacca via via via via ma che è
sento di tutti fortissimi via via via
come 10 scrap selector ha quindi quelle
foto non valgono e lo trovi proprio le
pagine o quanta roba lì ritrovare il suo
gioco ma sotto il cuscino anche la pasta
dignitoso ma c'è una casetta così che
c'è qua c'è una chiesa cos'è sta roba a
c'è un'asta bella o c'è una west con
termini non esca fleurs 3 le ho trovate
almeno non si sa dove ma lo trovate ne
mancano un miliardo e mezzo però lav e
chi se ne frega ma che è una tv batterie
ha trovato anche la pagina dai miei mi
derby holding bruciarlo in questo posto
o c'è anche il film che carino face una
foresta dove forse posso trovare
un'altra pagina perché è segnata eccola
lì porca vacca come sono bravo come sono
bravo
let's go bene questa è la skill skill
accumulata negli anni non vedo più
dovere il cartellone prima con tutta la
mia skill non lo trovo più ecco lo slate
germain guerra
where are you and me io e sto a chi in
deforesta but i can see you o siamo
arrivati all'albera ma non è un albero
ma porca vacca pisano su un albero fammi
entrare ma no dai tua sorella è chiusa
ritorniamo se ne in casa teoria dovrei
essere al sicuro in teoria è per la
morte del di gesù non lo so comunque ho
capito che posso diminuire la luminosità
con la rotella del mouse casa per la
prima sta cosa
porca vacca imortacci mia e kim ha fatto
di giocasta roba che so io quindi li
mortacci mi è basta perché non giochiamo
a hello kitty invece di star o guascone
abbracciami forte gesù cristo redentore
però è sì vabbè ma in scapito o è stai
calmo cribbio
manco l'ho visto io con la coda tra le
gambe via veloce anche
adesso ho capito perché non lo più di
fatto poi negli anni sto gioco c'era un
motivo è rotta tra cinque anni non mi
ricorderò di nuovo questo gioco fa paura
e lo rigiocherà di nuovo perché sono un
po scemo ti ho visto che cos'è quella
roba lì ho visto che cos'è ai la tv
porca vacca jesus christ veloce no no no
no no no no guascone to sorella
intanto però ragazzi direi che a basta
ho capito è cioè dio mio
ragazzi è stato ma guarda lo rifarei
adesso magari facciamo bella tutti i
ragazzi non sto scherzando me voglio
morire
quindi ragazzi spa video vi sia piaciuto
cosa non mi piace anche per i social con
la descrizione e noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video spero non so se lander me
perché no proprio no ragazzi
[Musica]